At today's talk will be speaking Coca Cola
A top level league in Japan
We have
their analyst Mr. Funato here today
Because I've also been playing rugby a lot
I think data analysts are the types that can
bring in talks that those in Google would
find interesting
There may be some who do not know that rules
of rugby
By the way, who here has no idea of the rules
in rugby?
Good, good, that's good
How about those who really like rugby?
I would like to talk about the type data we
deal with, something you might be interested
in
And hopefully we can receive input from you
Googlers
Where you can give suggestions on what we
can do with some data
The rugby industry is also trying to try out
different things
After today's talk, if there's a chance it
would be great we can talk more
So, shall we start?
Yes
Good evening.
I'll start with my introduction.
My name is Funato, an analyst for Coca Cola
Red Sparks
For the name Coca Cola Red Sparks
The base is in Fukuoka, and it's called Fukuoka
West, and it is under a Coca Cola franchisee
There is a rugby club there and that is where
I work as an analyst
This is my 9th year
I didn't play rugby as a child, but only started
playing it in high school
My height is the one thing I can't shed off,
and I stand 192 cm high
As of now, I have a slim figure
but when I was playing, I weighed about 120
kilograms
I was able to freely play rugby from high
school
And until now, I am still able to work as
an analyst for a sport that I enjoy
I have known Sori, for quite some time now
Thank you for giving me this opportunity
I would like to talk about the characteristics
of data in rugby
Earlier we've seen that some people don't
know much about rugby
So I would like to show you video clips
To understand what rugby is
This is from last year, and it is the highlight
of the Japan team from the Word Cup in England
There was also one analyst then, and his work
helped a lot for the game
For those that has never seen a rugby match
before might find it confusing
And to be honest, it is a 15 against 15 match
But it is all over the place
This is Goromaru from the TV CM that's always
playing these days
He will be going to France this year
The opponent is Scotland
We have scout the opponent and push their
weakness
He is also a professional player in Japan,
and plays with power
This is the match against America
This is a type of attack called maul
The Japanese team will gather like this, because
they are weaker in terms of strength
There are over 10 players, and when most of
the players get in there, and try (score)
The player that you saw in the last part,
he isn't very strong in the backs, but he
goes in and mixes with the rest
This is also from the match against America,
they are physically smaller, but they are
powerful when they get together
The opponent here is Samoa
Since they're islanders, when they get rough,
a lot players leave the game
But in this match, Japan managed to hold their
score at 0
This one, this is just looks like a bad accident
Even when I see it, this is a player I know
very well
I felt the intensity of the match seeing him
do that victory pose
He is a professional player that also plays
American Football, he has smooth movements
that allows him to doge opponents
That was a player almost 150 kilograms heavy
This one is a match against South America
The South American Team is about 3rd or 4th
on the global ranking
They were also one of the favorites
Japan got lucky in this match, and to be honest,
it was a messy game
Even the analyst didn't know who was taking
part in where
they would huddle together, get in one circle,
and get in a pack and attack forward
This is an example of perfect scouting, it
is a sign of perfectly seeing through the
opponent's information
This is a try that was chosen as one of the
best plays
This is where data played a big part
Eddie Jones was the coach here
They studied which players in the South African
team was weak at left tackling, which player
was weak at right tackling, and came with
complete statistics
As a result, it was a perfect assign where
they knew where to go to get score a try
If you get to this point, it's just all the
spirit working, and it's just fully passion
playing
This was the final try that became famous
The video you just saw
It is actually an unbelievable game that would
give you the chills
Japan played against South Africa who was
unbeatable, and prepared the best we could
They perfectly extracted data, and came up
with statistics of the South African team's
weak points
This was a well prepared for match where they
knew exactly what kind of game to expect when
they do what
On the actual game, with one minute remaining
on the clock, they scored a try and won
Everyone went wild with joy and surprise
This blew up the rugby industry in Japan
Rugby is a 15 against 15 game, and it has
the most competitive sport, the number of
players
Compared to other sports such as soccer, hockey
has 11 players, and rugby has 15
The ground is 100 meters by 70 meters, and
30 players would mix in this game
The quote at the bottom is by Ueda former
coach at Keio University
In soccer you cannot use your hands, in basketball
you can only use your hands, but in rugby
you can use all
You use the ball with your hands, with your
feet, and you hit with your body
It's like getting in a road accident, as you've
seen in the footage, it is a very aggressive
sport
With that said, it has very strict rules,
and it also keeps the spirit of fair play
With also the spirit of self-sacrificing,
and spirit of no side
It is the gentleman's sport, and originated
in England
We analyze and extract data of such an aggressive
sport with this number of players
As an example where I deliberately chose a
very big person
This is a foreign player that stands about
190 cm tall
With about 110 kg, and they have 130 kg players
too
But, of course, there are also players that
aren't even 180 cm tall, and less than 80
kg
With Japanese national team there are more
of these types of players
There are a lot of this level overseas
England's player Haskell played for Ricoh
in Japan
Spies also played for Kintetsu a Japanese
team, and we played against them
When I found out they were coming, honestly,
I felt bad for the players
Because, can you imagine, this would be coming
towards you
But the strategy is to dodge them well, and
we would come up with data on how to do this,
this is the Analyst's role
In rugby, New Zealand, South Africa, Australia,
Argentine, teams from the Southern Hemisphere
are usually strong
Islander teams such as Samoa, Fiji, and Tonga
are also strong
Then there's England, Europe, since it was
originated in England, there's England, France,
Wales, Scotland
These are the strong teams, and of course,
they are physically big
Plus, we see the U.S. flag here, but rugby
isn't actually that popular in the U.S.
When you say the 4 major American sports,
rugby won't really be mentioned
But, since this year there is the Rio Olympics
And rugby sevens became has officially been
recognized
What the U.S. first thought of was not to
get a Gold Medal, but to take advantage of
the business opportunity
So now, in the U.S., considering also the
business aspect of it, rugby is becoming very
popular
Of course, as we all know, with that population
size, there are a wide range of levels
If players from American football shift to
rugby
there are a lot of players in this level
That's why they are getting stronger and stronger
It's actually a threat globally
In Japan
The 2016 Japan team's performance you saw
earlier
I think you might have seen this
This is the Ninja pose of Goromaru who boomed
in Japan
I have 2 kids, and they do the pose all the
time
He is actually in an opposing team and it
is actually a bit troubling for myself
They would imitate him all the time, and would
ask me if he was around
He is from the team, Yamaha Hatsudouki
And my kids came when my team played against
him, and after the game they kept asking,
"Where is Goromaru?"
They don't even know the names of my team's
player, but they constantly mention Goromaru,
that is how famous he became
But thanks to him, rugby became very popular
If you all know, the world cup will be hosted
by Japan in 2019
There will be games all over the country,
and it is a great opportunity in terms of
business and rugby as a sport
Also, this year, actually this month, there
is also the Olympics
Both male and female team will take part in
the rugby seven games
I've mentioned earlier that it is a 15 against
15 game, but there are actually 3 types
The 15 against 15 is called union, and it
is the most famous type
Then, there's also the 13 against 13 called
League rugby
After that is the rugby seven, which also
uses the same grounds
In a 100 meter by 70 meter field, 7 against
7 would be playing, so the running ability
of the players is key
the players in the team is a collection of
all the speedsters
With these elements, rugby has become very
popular
In Japan, we have the Japan Rugby Top League
It is not the world's best, but it is Japan's
best rugby league with currently 16 teams
Our team Coca Cola Red Sparks is also in there,
and we are taking part in the matches
I assume there are some of you who have played
different types of sports
Not only in rugby, but coaches talk about
3 things
Mental, Technique, and Physical
There is the body, then one learns the technique,
and trains the mental
Basically what it means is that you must prepare
well, when all three are present, that is
where sports becomes important
Our job as analysts means that you cannot
win with simply this
What comes to play is another factor which
is intelligence
There is the rugby IQ, utilizing data, using
this data in scouting opponents
By doing so, the intelligence to make the
sport smarter and stronger is necessary
So working as an analyst, I would like to
roughly explain what I do as one
I mainly do 6 things
The first thing is preparing to record video
footage of practices, and analysis
Preparing for matches, analysis of the opposing
team, creating motivational video
Analysis of the actual match, our own Team's
analysis
I mainly do 6 things
During the season, there is a match once a
week, even in Japan
There would be a match on Saturday, and after
a week another match next Saturday
This cycle would go on every week
Simply put, we don't get to sleep much
And when there is a match, we don't get to
sleep at all
At the venue of the game, all we need is power
supply, and we can set up everything we need
In Japan's case, we would set up a video camera
Set the computer, set the desk, and also set
the DVD recorder
An analyst's base would be full of equipment
We would keep recording the match in video,
and take down the stats analysis
When we would see a pattern, then we would
inform the head coach immediately
We can keep track of which parts of the field
is often empty
Based on this, the coach would make the judgment,
and make appropriate directions
In the world cup footage you saw earlier with
the last try scene
During that time, if you watch the video again,
you can see that
The coach doesn't have his ear piece on
There is actually a story behind this
The coach gave instructions, but the player
ignored this and chose to make that play,
and as a result they won by scoring a try
The coach would ask why they didn't choose
to play the way he instructed, and he would
throw the headset in anger, and wouldn't be
able to make further instructions
The interpreter mentioned being questioned
by the fuming coach if they sent out the instruction,
and he said yes, but he said it was really
scary
That is how heated the players and the games
get, there's the data, but at the end of the
day, they go with the passion
Rugby is a game where you use data in this
way
Even after going to games all over the country
Even while in transit, on the plane, on the
bullet train, on the bus, will constantly
work on extracting data
It is all in here, with the analysis software
installed, we just constantly type those numbers
in
Even when we get home, we have to submit a
review to the coach by morning
So we just keep punching in those data
Aside from the matches, everyday during practice,
we have to video record
We then put this in the analysis software,
and we report the stats to the coach
On whether the intended purpose of that day's
practice was met or not
In preparing for games, we work from setting
up the equipment to setting up the data
For analyzing the opponent team
we gather videos of 3 to 4 matches they've
had
And extract information of what attacks they
make
And what defense they make
We also turn in the video footage as data
to the coaches
We also give them to the players so they can
see what attacks are made
The players would see the footage, and we
would go on to prepare for scouting
For the next task, it varies on the situation
whether we make it or not
But we also need to increase the player's
motivation
So, before important matches, we create motivational
videos
We capture the team's atmosphere, put in words
from the coach, so we always take on these
things
We then pick out footage, and create an about
5 minute video
At the hotel, we stay before the match, we
would show them the video, and we also put
it in their smartphones
This helps them keep their motivation high
Which would then lead to the kind of game
you saw earlier
Then, let's go into the main topic of this
talk which is what kind of data does rugby
deal with
There are mainly 3 types, and the first is
competitive data
First of all, let's talk about what competitive
data is
There are actually 3 kinds hidden here
First is the competitive data
As mentioned earlier, we have video footage
we record, so there is the data from the footage
There is also the team stats, individual stats,
and scouting stats
This is all the data a rugby analyst extracts
So, there's the video footage first
There is the team stats, where we come up
with data on the team's trend and patterns,
and what type of action or movements did the
team have
Then there is the individual stats
It might be a bit hard to see the specific
details
This is the team stats
This is the match when Japan was completely
defeated by New Zealand in the 2011 World
Cup
We will have to keep track of how many minutes
into the game was there a scoring through
try, and what kind flow the match had
There are types of play in rugby such as scrum
and line out
We track what was the success rate those had,
and how many times were there a tackle
Also, there's the possession rate, how often
did the players hold on to the ball
How much of the territory was gained
We single mindedly input this in the analysis
software
And more often
It would take 1 to 2 hours live
After that, it would take about 8 hours to
10 hours to extract all the data
We just keep going on and bringing in the
data
After doing so, we then work on the individual
stats
The individual stats are of the 15 players
I mentioned earlier, plus 8 reserves
That's a total of 23 members
So, as a strategy they all take turns
Basically, all 23 members take turns
We need to keep track of who was doing what
where for all the 23 players
This, to be honest, for us analyst, it is
dreadful
But we just keep on inputting that data
What happens is, as you have seen with rugby
in the footage
It gets all mixed up
Soccer has a tracking system, and as long
as you put a certain number of cameras
The video can distinguish the players in contrast
to the color of the field
So it is easy to extract data
But with rugby, it gets very confusing and
messy
Even for us
We end up constantly rewinding the tape, zooming
in, then checking who is doing what
Once we check then we input the data for each
player
So, as you can imagine, it is an extreme amount
of work
But, to improve the player's performance,
it is an essential factor
If there is work rate with low quality, then
we would need to work on eliminating this
Improvement would be necessary, so we just
have to keep bringing in the data
I am not sure how many hours it actually takes
I prefer not to count, because if I do, I
would just hate it more
We keep creating data
And, this is the competitive data
Plus, aside from our own team, we would also
work on analyzing the opponent's team
Aside from our match, and the ??? Of the next
opposing team there are 3 matches
There are about 4 matches to retrieve data
from
Then we find the patterns and trends, and
come up with the statistics
What will the opponent do, what kind of trend
or pattern we have, all of these are reported
to the coach
The second type of data is the mental and
physical type of data
In terms of the the mental, frankly, this
is quite hard to put into data
But in the physical side, we manage everything
in data
But we don't use a software for it
We don't have the go to software to manage
this
Basically, the height, weight, and body fat
Then there's the weight and muscles, how many
kilograms did they bench press lift
We also manage all the food they consume
Our team isn't really pro
Most of them are Japanese employees, and half
of them have families
We would get the permission of their wives
And we would rent out a whole dining hall,
and feed them dinner that our nutritionist
prepared
There's a time, 30 minutes after training,
that we call the "golden time"
How much we can feed them high protein and
low calorie food is what is important
So, that is what we feed them
It's been about 4 years since we started this
When we first started doing this, our team
players were physically small
Their bodies were small, and other teams had
190 cm and 100 kilogram players
And we didn't have a lot of players like that
But, these are the types of players we had
to play against, so what we did was
Just for dinner, we would make them eat 3,000
calories worth of food
These days a lot of people are conscious of
tracking their calories
So you could probably imagine what 3,000 calories
is like
Our players
Would have a hard time eating
It's easy to consume 3,000 calories when you
eat tempura or tonkatsu
but when the menu consists of boiled pork
Or white meat
When the food you have to eat is low calorie
high protein, and you have to consume 3,000
worth of calories
The players struggle to finish the food
But to finish their food is also part of the
training
And we ask them to also have control on these
When they feel hungry, the moment they feel
hunger, it means that their muscles are burning
So, they always carry nuts
Whatever they do they have nuts with them
to snack on
We joke about telling them they're like monkeys
But they are desperate
It's the same story during the Japan matches,
I have experience in working as Japan staff
It is just there
There are dried fruits and nuts put everywhere
It probably makes sense
But I'm not sure if people at Google train
They carry it around all the time, when we
headed to the plane, they would take it out
And when I asked what they were, they said
they were Almonds
And, this is typical during road trips
But this is something they do to train their
body
And lastly, there is also the subjective degree
of fatigue
There aren't a lot of data that measure the
degree of fatigue
The more well-versed the player is, the more
their perspective becomes objective
They would know how tired their body is and
which part is tired
We would ask them to rate from 1 to 5 of how
much which part hurts
When we continuously ask this, well-versed
players manage their bodies very well
There are also players who
Wear wearable watches, and manage their body
using their smartphones
We push them, and keep building the statistics
We also gather data that would prevent them
from having injuries
This also links
But we measure the speed that they run in
and their heart rate
Sorry if it's a bit hard to see but
This is made by the trainer that we use
Of individual physical data
There is no system for this, so currently
Our trainer, the S&C trainer we have made
this in an excel sheet
We would paste pictures from the top, and
there would be the name, position, age, and
height
The body fat of a certain weight would be
recorded
This is 24.5 close to 25, I think it's too
much
Then, if we keep focusing on the medical data
We end up wasting money, and also time
Actually we weigh them using just a standard
body fat scale you buy for your home
Then, once or twice a year we weigh them precisely
What we try to do here is to avoid any large
fluctuations
In his case when he gains here, he instantly
reduces
With this, if they gradually reduce body fat,
and increase muscle
You will be able to create a good body, and
as you can see here the target is 19 percent
To get close to the target 19 percent
When you work in being in the condition earlier
This is the muscle test
There's the power clean, squats, bench press,
pull ups
We measure the muscles that is our indicator
on how much it has been trained, and also
yearly
How much they have grown, how much they have
trained
This one is the speed related data
How much they can run
This is the kind of data we extract
Even for bench presses, there are no players
that don't not lift below 100 kg, for rugby
players
There are also those that lift more than 200
kg
They all have abnormal bodies
But to protect themselves from road accidents
as seen earlier
They have to put on muscle, and also extra
flesh
This is not American Football, with American
Football, you get to wear the head cap or
the helmet
There is a layer of protection, but in rugby,
there is nothing but flesh
To protect your body, we have to keep inputting
numbers and building the statistics
And manage your body
It was a bad example but
This is his medical history, and his injury
history
With this player, he had many injuries, and
he was very troubled by it
Players go through various injuries, with
that kind of play
In actual, even when they don't hit each other,
injuries happened even by just running
The moment they sprint, they can pull a muscle
These types of injury can also happen
He had been troubled by these injuries
And, he would constantly consult with the
trainer and doctor
Yesterday, we went to Hokkaido for training
camp
He was able to go through the camp without
any injury, and this year, might be a good
year for him
We record data like this
And we do take physical data like this
The body parts of the injury would show up
For this player, most of it is on his legs
and feet, so this indicates that he will need
to train these areas
Then, we would see how much he lifts during
squats
If we see that he lifts 190 kg
this may mean that he needs to lift more
If they were able to lift 135 kg during bench
press, then we see that it went down to 130
kg, we would ask the player why
We also pressure them because they need to
create a body that can endure a road accident
like game
With that said, this is how we manage physical
data
Finally
We would take both competitive data and physical
data
Player put on GPS
Nowadays, everyone uses the run meter on their
iPhones and smartphones when the run
There are also GPS devices in watches now
In rugby
It is about
A smaller size than this
There is a GPD device that is about 4 cm by
3 cm
They would put it on their shoulder blade,
and wear with something that resembles a sports
bra
The jersey used in regular games have pockets
to put them in
All the players would wear them
All 23 players
That would be 40 minutes times 40 minutes,
plus a little more, so the match would be
about 90 minutes
In 90 minutes, the player's running distance,
running time, the running time would be around
90 minutes
The running distance is how many km they run
The running speed, how was the intensity
What was the running speed at top speed
The average speed, the global average in rugby
For 1 match that runs for 80 minutes to 90
minutes is about 6.5 km to 7 km
With that said, since they are not marathon
runners, it doesn't mean that simply running
10 km or 20 km is enough
Within that 6.5 km, what is most important
is
The average speed, what this means is you
don't simply run 7 km
But a player must sprint and be on a constant
high speed to catch the ball that goes to
different places
A player that can continuously follow the
ball is the most clever player
By distinguishing the game everything appears
on the GPS
Then, of course, the speed increases, during
practice they would have they wear a heart
rate meter to count their heart rate
So, they would be pushed to increase their
heart rate to 180 to 200
When you try this out, you will understand
the intensity of 180
I'm sorry to assume, but I don't think anyone
can reach this
If you would, then you would probably be sent
to the hospital
That is how hard 180 to 200 is
The players are just panting and gasping at
this point
When I was a player
We would just get on our knees in exhaustion
and tell our coach we couldn't take it anymore
And it would look like we were exhausted
But now, since you can see everything, even
if the player begs you
We can see if the heart rate is only down
to 140, and we would tell them so
It might be a negative thought
But this is something that we can also manage
now
In a way, if it goes over 200, then we know
when it's too dangerous
We would tell them to stop, and go home to
rest
Or, we could ask them to skip practice the
next day
It also functions a barometer where we would
let them rest so they can manage their health
and condition themselves
There are different types of GPS software
In the software our team uses, this is the
GPS data of a player during practice
This green wave, is the speed data of the
GPS
The top orange line that fluctuates is the
heart rate
The higher it goes, it means the faster the
speed is
So, you can see that he runs, then at this
point he sprints
Then, he goes back then sprints again, and
goes back
Most likely, this pattern goes on for 3 times
This is probably a practice when the strength
coach gave him a heavy menu
The speed goes really fast, then they do it
for 3 rounds, and the heart rate continues
to be high
This practice probably goes on for 70 minutes
When it reaches the middle, they probably
have already warmed up
Then, the coach gave them an intense menu
This goes on for 3 sets
At the last part, they cool down, then the
heart rate also starts to go down
Every part of it is documented
They also wear this during the match, so the
running distance and speed during this would
show
And, this depends on the team
But there would be 5 different levels set
from low to high
Players that are consistently on level 4 and
5 are clever players
They regain their breath well, and can run
with strong intensity
If the player is weak, or not very skilled
They tend to stay on the lower levels
That's why they can't increase their speed
With this, it might not sound good if I say
that this is how we manage the players
But we extract competitive data and physical
data
Along with the GPS data
With soccer, they also use GPS
Apparently, it isn't as well known yet
In J league, they have started to use it as
part of fan service
Rugby uses this technology
As training data to increate the physical
and rugby IQ of the players
And this is only with rugby
As an example, I might also be out of the
rank
For example, baseball has progressed the most
Major league is really advanced in this aspect,
as a business and as a sport
The movie Moneyball is a good example of this
This is the movie starring Brad Pitt
They would extract the data called Sabermetrics
With baseball, there is no physical contact,
so it would be 1 on 1
This makes the data easy to come up with
They can come up with all sorts of data like
what is the on-base percentage of this batter,
what kind of pitch are they weak in
All sorts of statistic are created in Sabermetrics
If you're a professional athlete, it also
becomes your personal evaluation
Which would also lead to your salary, that
is the story in Moneyball
In Japanese Baseball, with Softbank Hawks
and Rakuten also uses this well
They would put foreign players in important
positions to supplement the team
Soccer also works on data management
In Soccer's case, there aren't much contact
between players too
So, it is easy to track their movements with
a camera
There is also GPS for this, and there are
rules that prevent them from putting one
So, they basically use the camera to document
everything, and they would come up with the
tracking data
Soccer fans are actually more into the game
more than the players
What has happened is that, I personally don't
play this, there are games such as Pro Evolution
Soccer and Let's Make A Soccer Team
The gamer becomes the coach
So when they watch a game live, they watch
it from the coach's perspective
There have been an increase in the number
of fans
That start to see if a player isn't being
productive
From a business perspective these fans need
to be taken care of
And they have to be satisfied
What the association is doing now, is that
they show all those data during half time
So when you go see a J league match now
During half time on the electric bulletin
board
You can see who has the longest running distance
and other data
But overseas they also put Sabermetrics here
But the data that we extract is simply data
of the past
It analyses a game that already ended
In a way, it's already ended so there is nothing
more to do
But, once these data are collected and you
build the statistics
The data that you extract from there, this
is actually what they do in NBA
You come up with the expected value
This is future numbers
For example, there is player A who is a batter
in baseball
You would extract the data from him, data
of him when he stands in the batter box
This means, they can up with data such as
this batter hits the most during a 2-2 when
there is a person on this fort
They will be able to come up with the expected
value of when to use a pinch-hitter
This is also the case with soccer, there is
the number of shoots made, and number of actual
shoots that turned to scores
Then they would know in which angle he has
a higher score rate
When his expected value is shown
They will see data of where and when he should
be used
A little while back
At that time, Okazaki's salary was not much
And his selling price wasn't much either,
at the beginning, he was just this small Japanese
dude
And, wasn't very popular in European soccer
Leicester's coach, if you didn't know any
better this guy just looked like
A typical middle aged looking man, was eyeing
Okazaki to scout
He looked through all his data and said, Okazaki's
running was exceptional
If we have this small dude just keep on running,
he will suit Leicester
And, his salary was low and cheap to scout,
so he picked them out
He told him, we are relying on you, this is
your expected value
And if you work on this area, you will be
great for Leicester
And, as a result of Okazaki's performance,
Leicester won
This is a result from the expected value,
this is Sabermetrics
This has not entered rugby yet
Sabermetrics is already in soccer, basketball,
and baseball
You do not simply use the data from the past,
but you extract this data and come up with
an expected value
This is the new way data is now being used
There have been talks that rugby will have
this too
But the system is still not built, and it
is still hard to build at this point
Before I talk about the next topic
If you have anything to ask about data, please
ask
I would like to answer the best way I can
About how data is used in sports
(Question)
Most of the time the strength coach manages
this
Of course it is not good to just keep bulking
up
But since it is the human body, it is hard
to give a set of standards
Of course they always consult with the doctor
and trainer
But there isn't a set standard
But what often happens in sports is
For example, in our team there is a player
that stands 160 cm
He states he is that tall, but we are not
quite convinced
His nickname is Tank
He weighs about 100 kg
And he bench presses about 165 kg
If there was a picture, I would like to show
you
But what happens to a 160 cm, 100 kg player
that bench presses that much
You end up looking like a tan
This is it
Just imagine having arms here
Since this is what he looks like, his arms
do not lift, and it just statistics
This would affect his performance, so we control
it
We make him lose weight
This is what happens in rugby
For example, in other games, such as volleyball
In volleyball, if a player bench pressed and
put on muscle, you would think they can spike
well
But with bench press you can only gain muscle
at the front
When you train it too much, to exaggerate
a little, the shoulders would stiffen
When this happens, you would bring it to the
back when you perform a spike, but your shoulders
would be too stiff
If you don't control this, you're body won't
be able to spike anymore
It depends on the sport, and the individual
players
There actually isn't a standard to it
We look into the balance
And we ask them to train, and play in matches,
and based on the results we control
(Question)
We manage all of those
Usually the players know themselves
They would know what would match what kind
of weight
For example, for really professional players,
since it is better to be able to take up a
variety of positions
There are those that can manage how much weight
is needed for certain positions
There are players that are able to manage
in this way
We also have a player that holds on 3 different
positions
They won't be able to switch by week
We would ask him to take a certain position
by season
Then he would say okay then I will do 105
kg
Then we would ask him to do a running positions
Then he would say okay I will do 98 kg
He can control it in this way
Kuwazuru is the rugby seven captain
He is a member in our team
When he was playing rugby union, he would
do 100 kg
In rugby union, there is a lot of running,
so he would lower it to 95 kg
He also lost weight for Rio, and we would
bully play with him that he wasn't part of
the team anymore
But to play in the Olympic, he will not be
able to run if he is too heavy
He manages the weight
The player works with the trainer to manage
this
Thank you
Yes, please
(Question)
Thank you
Actually, rugby has not progressed that much
It might be wrong coming from me
But we've always had high level analysts in
rugby
But because the association does not have
much influence
There were a lot of ignorance towards data
Currently, we are left behind by soccer, basketball,
and volleyball
I always check out soccer
About the data of soccer
Even though it is very different sport
How can we increase the winning rate, with
what we call a try
To be able to score a try, what are the procedures
we have to go through
Before, you had to have a high possession
rate of the ball to score a try
The time the ball is held within the 80 minutes
of game
It has always been said if a team holds on
to the ball 60 percent of the time, then they
would win
But in rugby these days, you can win even
without possessing the ball
This is also happening in soccer
The idea that if you possess the ball, you
can shoot or you can score a try
If you think about it this is common sense
Yes, this concept does not fade
But in actual, for example, currently the
strongest team is England
When England and Australia played against
each other
England had a landslide win with 7 against
But when you look at the stats, the possession
rate of Australia is 75%
England wasn't able to attack at all, but
they won
So, what is happening here, let's see
There is no ???, they want to come up with
the expected value
But in terms of if the coach's strategy and
the expected value is another issue
This is also one of the troubles an analyst
faces
First thing is the coach has to have a creative
result ahead when they see the data
And, what is also difficult is
In Japanese sports, the coaching style is
still passion first
It is what they called having the balls
So regardless how much data we bring in
They would often dismiss it is as merely numbers
There was a NBA player named Brent Barry
The owner of the team he was in
Was actually a statistician, which was completely
unrelated to basketball
But there was the Sabermetrics we mentioned
earlier, and they named the owner the pro
in statistical science
The players did not take well that they were
being evaluated merely by two dimensional
numbers
And with this, what he said was, and this
is completely a sexist comment
Stats are just like bikinis, they are nice
to look at
But they don't tell you the whole story
There are a lot of women here so I feel very
rude saying it
He said it, not me
As a man, ultimately, they want to see a naked
woman
But stats is like a bikini that looks good
But since what you really want to see is a
naked woman
Stats is like that, it won't let you see the
truth
When he said this to the media, which poked
him a lot for this
But it is exactly as he said
Honestly, this is the agony of an analyst
Regardless of what numbers you come up with,
in the end, it is just numbers
In actual, when those players move in the
field, their passion comes first
During the South African match earlier, the
Japan vs South Africa
As per the data, Japan can aim for getting
a penalty goal
When they get 3 points, it will be a match,
and the world will see how great Japan is
This was the intention of the coach
This is as per the data
But, when you're on the field, it's your passion
that comes first and say, I will score with
a try
As a result it turned out okay
And everyone celebrated it
But as for the coach, he was upset that they
didn't listen to his data and threw the headset
in frustration
This is honestly a distress
In our case, we have been playing rugby for
a while
Even before, the approach on strategy
Has always changed
If the opponent kicks, we would have to count
the number of counter attacks
Or it could be increasing the number of line-ups
within the 22 meter line
This changes through time
After a while, it becomes obsolete, and something
of the past
It consistently changes
So, it makes the approach very difficult
Especially in rugby, the rules change every
year
For those who started to like rugby
It might be wrong to say that it is a shame
But we also have a hard time keeping up with
the changes every year
Since turning pro is a trend right now, they
see rugby as a business
And they want to make rules to make the game
more interesting
So, since there are changes in the rules every
year
Even the referee cannot keep up
Everyone is having trouble with this
The audience aren't sure what happens in games
But it is something we cannot fix
As mentioned by Mr. Sorimatsu earlier
This goes with soccer too
But there is a play that the player can control
For example, in rugby, there is line-out
There is the ball the opponent kicks
Then the player can throw-in from the side,
this is a play where one throws the ball
This is something the player can perform when
they kick the ball and the opponent kicks
it
But in the case of scrum which is another
set play, the player cannot control it
With soccer, throw-in can be controlled
You can kick it to the front, put pressure,
then the opponent will start kicking
When the number of this increases
The strategy they make is to make a lot chances
to score by using a throw-in
Does anyone here know the England vs Iceland
match
This is the game Iceland won in
In soccer, England is one of the strongest
Iceland on the other hand, is not known for
soccer
Even when you look at their stats, their success
rate in passing is very low in rank
But they won 2 to 1 to against England
The whole country celebrated
Their strategy was to use throw-in to build
their strength and have control
They came up with the stats and used this
as the source of attack
Then when they ride the waves
The players start to think that they have
what it takes to win
And finally they are driven by passion
This is the kind of data that was done in
soccer
Is everything alright?
Finally, I don't mean butter up
There is Coca Cola Red Sparks in Google app
Even before Mr. Sorimachi asked me to talk
here
My team
We ask all our players to install these 4
apps to their smartphones
Thanks to these, it has helped us a lot, this
is true
Firstly, we asked everyone to make a Gmail
account
And, if we need to announce or share something,
we can contact them immediately
These can be changes in schedule, or watch
this match
Or when something else happens, we can manage
everything in one place
There is Google Drive, but we put all the
compressed data in Drive
The players use their smartphones, iPads
Tablets or desktop to download these
In this training camp, you will see the pictures
later, we also used it
It has been very helpful
There is also playbooks, we send all the files
Then we used the calendar for schedules
In meetings we also have foreigners and Japanese
We don't speak English at all
And we have an interpreter while the coach
is a foreigner
Then the coach would speak in English, and
we wonder what they talk about
We might understand some of it, then the interpreter
would talk straight
Then it would get confusing for the meeting
to be clear
We put the meeting agenda in the calendar
first
Then, it would be easier to follow the conversations
The meeting minute would then be uploaded
to drive, and send through Email
Finally, we use Youtube to share the matches
the players should watch
We would look through the videos to visualize
the kind of game we want to play
We ask them to check some pages
This is something we ask them to do
In actual, the AD Japan 2015 we saw earlier
They were all using this
What we did was called the analyst immediately
and asked to use it
Thankfully, everything else is free aside
from the communication fee
Thank you very much, it has been great help
This allows us to have very creative meetings
This is what it looks like
This is after getting back to the hotel yesterday
They would all put it in their tablets
And watch it right there
This is a foreign player, and there is one
spot in the hotel that has strong wifi
He was just watching all night
In the plane, since our base is in Fukuoka,
the time in transit is long
It takes 1 to 2 hours to Tokyo, to Hokkaido
it takes 1 to 2 hours too
Since we don't want to waste time in transit,
they would watch the videos they download
during transit
This is a very important time
Of course sleeping is also important
But we focus on maximizing the transit time,
and we ask them to download into their tablets
These 3, 4 apps have helped us
On top of that, our staffs and managers
We tour nationally
There are a lot places that we've never visited
before
So we open Google Map
From the moving bus we use, we check the remaining
time to arrive to the hotel
When we are about to get there, we call them
up and tell them to prepare the players
Sometimes it is also hard to get to the venue,
and we check if there are convenience stores
around
Or what are other establishments there are
close by
The traffic and all other information, we
research everything
Lastly, there is translations during communication
with foreign staff
It is hard to always have the interpreter
around
We use these tools
To read English documents, and also partially
for when communicating
It has helped us a lot in these situations
In moving around in the field, and coming
up with data
Thankfully, we just use Google apps
To finish it off, we continue to fight to
win
We say that this is how we utilize data
But your apps have managed to help us with
this
We would like to finish this year by winning
We also have games in Tokyo, we hope that
you can come and see us play
This is where I end my talk
This was about the utilization of data in
rugby
That is all
Thank you very much